it's seven o'clock this is Skinny's
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning for you
Dominic Robb accuses a small minority of
activist civil servants of plotting to
force him out and trying to block
government reforms
Civil Service unions hit back saying
he's peddling a dangerous conspiracy
theory to deflect criticism of his own
conduct
also ahead for you the CBI in crisis the
business lobbying group suspends all
operations after major companies quit
30 years on from the murder of Stephen
Lawrence his father tell Sky News he
still can't trust the police
as long as as they can't accept what
they're doing is wrong
because if you don't accept it it's not
going to change
I'm the health secretary Steve Barclays
says he'll go to court to stop nurses
striking at the end of the month
in sport a dramatic comeback for Arsenal
as they draw 3-3 with bottom Club
Southampton but it's vital points drops
in a title race
and at quarter two we take a look at the
papers with national world cities
editor-in-chief Nancy Fielder as well as
broadcaster Pete price
[Music]
hello good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast well former deputy prime
minister Dominic Raab has accused what
he calls activists civil servants of
forcing him out of office Mr Robb
resigned after an independent
investigation upheld two complaints that
he bullied officials but he says some
civil servants were trying to block
policies they didn't like including
brexit and now the Prime Minister Rishi
sunac is facing questions about his own
judgment after losing three senior
ministers in six months our political
correspondent Joe Pike reports have you
got a new job I have no idea just six
months after he walked into government
and maybe he's going for a stroll down
uh Whitehall he's out but not leaving
quietly almost all of the complaints
against me were dismissed and what this
doesn't give you it's a handful of very
senior officials none of the uh junior
complaints were upheld and I got on and
dealt with hundreds of civil servants
thousands of other people in prison
service in the court service Dominic
Raab argues there is now a low threshold
for proving bullying which sets a
dangerous precedent but two of eight
formal complaints about his conduct were
upheld his behavior was found to be
intimidating and unreasonably and
persistently aggressive what I think
this shows is the continual weakness of
the Prime Minister because there's a
double weakness here he should never
have appointed him in the first place
along with other members of the cabinet
that shouldn't have been appointed and
then he didn't sack him Oliver downed a
long time soon act loyalist is the new
Deputy pm and Alex chalk the Justice
secretary but fresh faces can't distract
from another painful departure we've now
had three cabinet ministers leave their
jobs in the just six months Rishi sunak
has been prime minister two of them for
bullying advisors here will now be
hoping most of this dies down ahead of
the local elections in less than a
fortnight as for Dominic Raab a
ministerial comeback seems unlikely
before the next election and as his
constituency is marginal he could soon
lose his job as an MP too Joe Pike Sky
News Westminster
our political correspondent Amanda acass
joins me now from Westminster so Amanda
Mr Rob's description there of some of
the civil servants as activists in this
context it's explosive yes so for a man
brought down by claims he'd been
intimidating and aggressive towards
civil servants Mr Robb notoriously a
black belt in karate has definitely gone
out fighting after his bullish
resignation letter he then issued a
whole series of interviews in which he
made a whole set of different
allegations against civil servants
describing them as activists overly
unionized conspiring together to bring
him down and also deliberately
obstructing government policy in areas
they disagreed with like brexit and
human rights reform now this is a very
serious allegation because civil
servants are meant to be impartial at
the same time they're also meant to be
free to speak truth to power and give an
informed opinion and this really kind of
highlights the difficulties of doing
that at times now all of this was a red
flag
um to a bull to the FDA Union which
represents senior civil servants already
balloting over strike action so
relations not even particularly good to
start with
um they've described his comments as a
conspiracy theory and said the Prime
Minister should be doing more to defend
civil servants I think there is quite a
deal of anger in some of the Departments
affected that uh in the very warm tone
we saw in the letter the Prime Minister
sent back to Mr Rob although he did say
it was right that he had decided to
resign and the fact that he wasn't
actually sacked before that happened I
think all of that really fans the sense
that this is another front in the
culture War these allegations from some
MPS that these uh claims by civil
servants are symptomatic of a kind of
woke culture even though that's
something that was dismissed within the
report now labor and the opposition
party say the Prime Minister looks very
weak over all of this and he's got a big
policy agenda to deliver before the next
election for which he needs a civil
service on the side so he really will be
hoping to try and draw a line under this
as soon as possible but at the moment
that's definitely not happening
okay Amanda thanks for that good to hear
from you
well Dominic Robb's resignation
dominates this morning's front pages
let's take a look closely though Rob
quits in Fury that's the lead for the
guardian there
what about the times they say Mr Rob
went down swinging in the face of what
he says was a tyranny of subjective hurt
feelings
the I meanwhile says that civil servants
who worked under him well they're angry
at what they call his tone deaf
resignation
and uh the mirror bully beef reads their
front page calling his behavior
sickening
but not all of the papers are critical
Mr Rob the express quotes allies saying
he was forced to quit just for wanting
the best for Britain
Telegraph reports in the end it was a
row over a plan to put Spanish forces on
the ground in Gibraltar during brexit
negotiations that actually scuppered Mr
Robb and the male asks if this was the
day the country became ungovernable when
a top cabinet minister was forced to
quit for hurting the feelings of civil
servants
now the confederation of British
industry has suspended all activity
until June after dozens of major
companies quit the organization the
lobbying group is in crisis after a
second woman claimed she was raped while
working for the CBI our business
correspondent Paul Kelso has this report
for almost 60 years the CBI has claimed
to speak for business but that Voice May
soon fall silent after some of Britain's
biggest companies rushed to end their
association with the lobby group The
Crisis began with reports of serious
misconduct including an allegation of
rape against a senior manager as an
office party on the Thames now a second
woman has alleged she was raped by two
CBI employees working at an overseas
office triggering a flood of companies
to suspend or end their membership
including NatWest Virgin Media BT
AstraZeneca Ford and meta owners of
Facebook the companies we're talking
about today they have deep values and
they have leaders who follow through on
that that values within their own
workplace I think after it's point it
becomes untenable for them to remain in
a situation where there is a string of
very very serious allegations
the CBI has already sacked its director
General Tony danker for unrelated
misconduct he says made him a scapegoat
now the organization has effectively
Frozen day-to-day business and signaled
the CBI as we know it may be over
in a statement the CBI board said we
have taken the difficult but necessary
decision to suspend all policy and
membership activity until an
extraordinary general meeting in June at
the egm we will put forward proposals
for a refocused CBI to our membership
for them to decide on the future role
and purpose of the organization John
Lewis is one of dozens of household name
businesses that have walked away from
the CBI and the government has already
said it won't talk to the lobby group
while investigations are ongoing without
the confidence of its members or the ear
of Menace as a CBI can't make the case
for business and plainly can't promote
best practice future is in serious doubt
the members who've called the cbi's fate
into question will decide if it still
has a voice in the summer Paul Kelso Sky
News
the Royal College of nurses has accused
the health secretary Stephen Barclay of
trying to bully them now nurses have
rejected a five percent pay offer from
the government which has announced that
it will go to court to try and stop
strikes planned at 130 NHS trusts in
England on the 30th of April on the 1st
of May not NHS employers wrote to the
RCN saying the strike is unlawful
because it believes its mandate for
industrial action ends at midnight on
May the 1st
well in a statement Mr Barclay said the
government firmly believes in the right
to strike and it's vital that any
industrial action is lawful and I have
no choice but to take action This legal
action also seeks to protect nurses who
could otherwise be asked to take part in
unlawful activity that could in turn put
their professional resignation at risk
well the heads of the RCN Pat Cullen
said the decision was nakedly political
and nurses will not be gagged into this
way by bullying government the
government is now desperate to silence
nurses rather than address this properly
and she adds we want to be in the
negotiating room not the courtroom
Cullen there now Stephen Lawrence's
father has told Sky News that he will
never forgive the police as he marks 30
years since his son's murder the 18 year
old was killed in an unprovoked attack
while he was waiting for a bus in
southeast London now the inquiry into
the failed police investigation has
found there had been institutional
racism in the Met it took nearly 20
years which brought two of his five
killers were jailed for murder Mr
Lawrence was speaking to Sky Shimon
Freeman Powell who began by asking about
Stephen's aspirations to become an
architect
looking forward to seeing some of his
the building that maybe you decide
design and build all over the country
unfortunately for me and my family that
didn't happen
for three decades the Lawrence family's
life has been turned upside down in
their Quest For Justice a police
investigation tainted by racism meant it
would take 20 years for just two of five
of Stephen Lawrence's Killers to be
jailed I keep saying to people that I've
got so far is some justice and when I
say some justice that's mean I want the
whole Justice
and what does a whole Justice look like
all Justice sort of get all the other
people that were involved in my son
murder
to go and spend time in prison for what
they've done I think it would be really
a court courteous for them for me to ask
whosoever
is being sent to prison
did you actually kill my son I want you
to say yes I killed Stephen Lawrence and
the police have a lot to answer for too
it was a report looking into the
investigation of Stephen Lawrence's
death that would go on to call Britain's
largest police force institutionally
racist for the very first time and as
early as this year a new review found
that not much has changed I would never
forgive the police
as long as as they can't accept
what they're doing is wrong
because if you don't accept it it's not
going to change we still facing the same
kind of attitude of these people who
supposed to be protecting the Republic
and I've made it plain to people if
something happened to me tomorrow
morning or even now who do I call
and if I had to deal with the police I
wouldn't be calling a bunch of problem
police because I know I wouldn't get the
satisfaction of them treating me the way
it is supposed to but Neville does
acknowledge that the wider Society
progress has been made
progress carried by a new generation
inspired by his son's Legacy for them to
do things different from the ways some
of their parents were doing it I'm I'm
feel grateful for that the only thing
that I'm
not too happy about is that it had to
take the death of my son
for anything like that to happen
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News
well joining me now is former
superintendents in the metropolitan
police and former chair of the black
Police Association charitable trust it's
Leroy Logan thank you so much for
joining us here at Sky News good morning
to you
um I just wonder if you would take me
back to your reflections of that night
and the weeks and the days that followed
I was 11 when that happened and it was
one of the very first time that a news
story really affected me because I had
fear fear for my dad who had dreadlocks
my brother who was of dark skin
um but what about your Reflections yeah
well I was part of the black Police
Association and even though I was based
in North London at the time there was
definitely a sense of dread
on you know you could relate to the
Lawrence Family and Stephen could have
been my brother my cousin Etc so it it
it had that real sort of relevance and
hurt and pain and it's that this case
has always been a touchstone for the
black community
um you know I'm very privileged
especially since giving evidence that
McPherson inquired to the death of
Stephen
and I was one of the officers who said
that the the Met was institutely racist
um we we got to know the Lawrence Family
and um you know it's great to
um have that sort of conversation with
uh Neville and Doreen because they gave
their Humanity uh such dignity
um and they would Challenge and they
wouldn't be gaslighted and said
everything's fine they always stood the
their um their Corner stood in their con
very strong and it gave us a real sense
of how to put ourselves across in the
black Police Association and to not
um
acquiesce but to say it as it is and
because we're part of the black
community and we speak up on behalf of
the black community and in particular
the lawrencies and what they were going
through so it had so many
um overlaps uh with me personally I
think also you know I'm a Jamaican
Heritage similar to uh the Lawrence
Family and so I can relate to them in
that respect as well what did you make
of the lawrences I'd say dignified fight
for justice and and I said to you while
we were watching shiman's report there
actually you don't hear from Neville
very much but what were your early
indications of their their fight for
justice
well their grit and determination that
they needed to know what had happened to
their son
um obviously they know he was killed uh
by uh races in the community but why
weren't they arrested because there was
a lot of information at the time
um how why wasn't this acted upon and
obviously they'd start to find out that
there was a collusion with the family
there was corruption
incompetence and to some extent and of
course they realized that there was a
racial element to it and um and then
they start to look wider and and see
that this wasn't just a one-off you know
the way in which uh Stephen murdered was
investigated and and as a result of that
they sensed that there was a wider issue
of institutional racism that needed to
be addressed and I think that's why
um Nelson Mandela when he came over he
totally identified with the case and as
a result of that he spoke up on their
behalf which really resonated with the
labor party and then because this was
the sort of mid-90s and obviously the
election in 97 they were voted in and
that the labor party totally accepted
that there was issues to deal with
policing in a way that had to be
addressed and it couldn't be left
um ongoing and kicked into the long
grass had to be dealt with them and and
I was really pleased when the Home
Secretary Jack straw announced the um
McPherson inquiry and it was a statutory
inquiry so it wasn't just another
reporter review but it had teeth and it
could hold the police to account because
I truly believe there's nothing wrong
with them I can't be addressed by what's
good in it it just needs the right
leadership it needs the right political
will to hold into account to make it the
the Police Service more accountable and
transparent and it's very similar to
police forces across the country and and
it just really needed that sort of
political will and independent oversight
of not only the report but the
recommendations and how they were going
to be rolled out because what gets
measured gets done and that was the
important thing about those
recommendations because they made and
that there were Watershed in terms of
policing and changing policing for for
the better so you fed into that 1999
McPherson report talk to me about the
the cultural changes that happened
within the Met police in that 10-year
period
well immediately the Casual racism the
n-word the P were the W word stopped
right so they realized you know that the
bad cops knew there to shape up and and
it created a positive atmosphere so the
good cops would call out the bad cops
their diversity inclusion
um was you know the
golden thread going through so many
different forms of
um policing issues it had operational
effectiveness and
um I was able to uh show how uh
complaints within the organization
reducing complaints by the community was
reducing policing policing was was a
light touch it wasn't a heavy-handing
people felt uh the police were for them
instead of feeling over-policed and
underprotected
um so and it's because the independent
oversight was there holding the police
to account through the Stephen Lawrence
Steering group chaired by Jack straw at
Neville and Dorian Lawrence in that
group and I was one of the um people as
chair of the national black Police
Association to be privileged to be on
that group but I was also in the room
when Paul Condon said these are
recommendations we've been called
institutional racism we will use it as
an aspiration to be better
not to go into some Antics or Gaslight
but to say listen we can be the Police
Service that the public demand so it's
really interesting to get your thoughts
then finally Mr Logan and where you see
the metropolitan police at the moment
we've had recent report that said it's
institutionally homophobic xenophobic
racist
is the right man in charge to push the
Met into the place where it needs to be
well I know Mark Rowley was in the met
when um
leading up to chrisella Dick taking up a
commission ship it sadly it reminds me
the look and feel of policing reminds me
of a premchpherson era it seems to be
more of an occupying Force as you say
the case you report showed not only
um that the
certain units like the Parliamentary and
diplomatic protection group or is that
safe haven Predators you know
Carrick and cousins all of these people
which you think never would happen if
there wasn't the checks and balances if
supervisors uh were doing the job they
weren't being protected there wasn't
that culture of fear that prevented the
good cops calling out the bad cops and
those systemic failures were being dealt
with in a way that you started to see
um real significant change and of course
the political Will's not there
um to hold the commission and the chief
constables have come and that's why the
commissioner can say oh well I don't
believe I'm an Institutional racism so
that that until you acknowledge you have
a problem you've got to do something
about it so I don't think Mark Rowley is
really equipped to deal with it because
he was there when he was going bad yeah
I I you know when they come through that
culture they're very protective you know
they don't keep that critical distance
and they're not able to really do the
sustainable change that's going to hold
that Police Service that met and the
rest of the police services around the
country to the level of um integrity and
ethics and professional behavior and of
course getting the basics right that's
why the Mets in special measures because
they're not even just getting the basics
right around how to police London okay
Mr Leroy Logan pleasure to have you in
the studio today thank you for your
thoughts
okay we'll have an extended interview
with Stephen Lawrence's father Neville
at 9 30 12 30 and 8 30 tonight so to
tune in
okay time now for the sport with James
hi yeah you're right yeah it's going by
quite quickly I think James ready for uh
action-packed weekend of sport including
live in Madison on Sunday which I
believe you have run before yes never
again I'm afraid never again it makes me
sad that really does make me sad I've
run it once as well and I want to do it
again I loved it but look uh coming up
we'll look ahead to today's FA Cup
semi-final between Manchester City and
Sheffield United Peck Guardiola talks
about a possible treble uh plus a big
boost for Manchester City's title hopes
with Arsenal dropping points last night
all the drama from that game on the way
and we'll round up the tennis as Dan
Evans makes it through to the
semi-finals of the Barcelona open
thank you
good morning we've got all the action
from a drama-filled premier league
encounter between top of the table
Arsenal and Southampton last night plus
we'll look ahead to today's FA Cup
semi-final or between Manchester City
and Sheffield United
brought to you by Vitality oh I think
we're gonna crash sharing the benefits
of healthy living
oh dear oh dear that's not going to make
the highlights sorry
but there really is only one place to
start and that's with all the drama from
last night's Premier League game where
Arsenal fought back from two goals down
to draw thrill with Southampton but it
still meant they dropped two more
crucial points in the title race now
arsenal were behind after just 28
seconds and Aaron ramsdale's attempt to
play out from the back presenting Carlos
alcaraz with that chance to put
Southampton in front
[Applause]
also with two down in the 14th minute
even worse it was their former player
Theo Walcott who scored and that led to
the unusual sight of the whole team
holding a meeting on the pitch
it seemed to do the trick though as
Arsenal hit back soon after because
cross from the right was met by Gabriel
Martinelli who volleyed in his 15th goal
of the Season still 70 minutes left for
the Premier League leaders to come back
but the Emirates Stadium was stunned by
the bottom of the table side when DJ
chilletta Char made it 3-1 to
Southampton
also gave themselves a glimmer of hope
when Martin erdogard scored two minutes
from time
and they're more late drama but kayosaka
scoring for Arsenal as they entered
eight minutes of added on time
Arsenal pushed hard for a winner and
almost got it Leandro trossard had a go
from range only to hit the crossbar a
draw does move Arsenal Five Points clear
of Manchester City at the top although
their Rivals have two games in hand a
huge game on Wednesday night when the
top two face each other at the Etihad
I love our players more than ever you
know because make a mistake you make
another mistake and then it's
complicated when when you are really
fighting for what we are fighting
um to turn that around and change the
energy and have the chorus to play later
when we have played it's incredible
we show character we show a different
variations of what we can do and then we
are proud of the of the work and the
ethics and the and uh as we did as a
unit together and that's the way that we
need to follow from now until the end of
the season
Manchester City will it be boasted by
Arsenal's draw last night but the games
come thick and fast for them starting
with today's FA Cup semi-final with
Sheffield United and manager Pep
Guardiola has played down talk of
winning all three competitions they're
still in common in terms in this amazing
country travels I've done how many years
how much how many times how many dimes
is one you know our neighbors they did
it you know say how many centuries so we
are more closer to don't do it than do
it
this is into the semi-finals of the
Barcelona open after a three-step
victory over Francisco surrenderlo but
the British number two had to come down
come from set down to be at the
Argentinian he'll now face world number
two Carlos alcaraz in the last four
we're back in the next album build up to
all of today's football is over on Sky
Sports News
oh look a frisbee
no no it's a boomerang
this is Skinny's breakfast coming up
it's Dominic Rob wakes up to his first
morning outside of government we'll get
the analysis of what his explosive
resignation means from two former
political advisors
[Music]
good morning you're watching Skinny's
breakfast our top stories this morning
Dominic RAV accuses a small minority of
activists civil servants so plotting to
force him out unions report that he's
peddling can conspiracy theories
Confederation of British industry has
suspended all activity until June after
dozens of major companies quit the
organization
Stephen Lawrence's father has told Sky
News that he will never forgive the
police as he marks 30 years since his
son's murder
well let's get more on the resignation
of the Deputy Prime Minister a report
found Mr Rob's conduct during his time
in the foreign office accounted to an
abuse or misuse of power that undermined
or humiliated his staff while here to
discuss this with me or two former
political advisors Sonia soda and Andy
McKeever thank you so much both of you
for joining us where to start this
morning but I think a good place Sonia
is just to talk about how Dominic Robb
left that resignation and I suppose the
tone
well I think it was um an apology that
was one of one of those apologies that's
really a non-apology it was very defiant
it wasn't contrite at all despite the
fact that in this report by an
independent Casey he'd been found uh to
have believed colleagues on on two
occasions and that his conduct in the
workplace was unacceptable
um and it was essentially him saying uh
well I'm sorry if anyone felt offended
but how was I supposed to know and um
you know the process was stacked against
me so it was quite an extraordinary uh
tone of resignation letter in that
response I think it shows that he
doesn't really think that he thought
anything uh he did anything wrong and
then we saw that in an article he went
to the Telegraph and an interview he
gave to the BBC afterwards and he
essentially seemed to be suggesting that
he'd been victimized by civil servants
who had an agenda against him but the
thing that he really has to take into
account is this was an independent
report done by Casey a very
distinguished lawyer who conducted a
full and thorough investigation
found that so there wasn't evidence
there wasn't sort of corroborating
evidence to support some of the
allegations against him doesn't mean
that they they didn't happen it means
that we don't know that they they
happened
um but you know that that that his
behavior in the workplace was
unacceptable
um on some occasions and um the Casey
who wrote the report Adam Tolley says
that the civil servants brought their
claims forward
um they you know they had Integrity they
did it in good faith and they had no
ulterior motive and yet you've got
Dominic Robb on the other hand you know
talking about activist civil servants
and a conspiracy to bring him down and
I'm afraid it just looks like somebody
who doesn't understand that they're a
bully doesn't understand how their
behavior is perceived in the workplace
the detrimental impacts it has and
somebody who's claiming victimization
and and it's in in doing so undermining
the independent civil service and Andy
where does this leave Rishi sooner
because what it feels like is Dominic
Robb has left this bombshell calling a
minority group of civil servants
activists trying to block government
reform
I mean I think at the moment the story
is probably more about Rab in the acute
sense than it is about tsuna look
everybody involved in politics even you
know whether they've met Rob or not
everybody involved in politics knew the
reputation that Dominic grab had for
really quite some time before
um and you know whether individual
complaints were upheld or not everybody
understands that he has been an
exceptionally difficult person to work
for so I don't think there will be a
huge amount of sympathy for Dominic grab
I also don't think that at the moment
there's a mass amount of blame pindered
which is too nice and I do think that in
situations like this we can overestimate
the impact it will have on the Prime
Minister and on the government Russia's
United's already been through the Nadeem
zahawi issue and already being through
the Gavin Williamson issue so he's lost
two cabinet ministers already and of
those two and and now Dominic Rabb you
would think that from the public
Consciousness point of view because it
involves money and when it involves
money and sleeves and the Tories it can
tend to be more damaging you've thought
that because of that then it seems a
hammy one would have been the one that
stuck around the most but actually the
poor ratings generally for Russia I mean
are obviously not good but the poor
ratings generally foreign have been
getting better and haven't usually been
sidetracked too badly by these
individual issues of cabinet ministers
remaining so my my impression would be
that this Dominic grab story will hang
around it will contribute to General
history the Tories have at the moment
but I actually don't think in an acute
sense it will make a huge amount of
difference
lots of people saying Sonia actually if
you lose your number two it's a bad day
in Downing Street whichever way you look
at it and then we have to talk about I
suppose the local elections you know
Rishi sunak's first big test here
um and whether any of this will cut
through to voters
but of course it's about day when your
Deputy Prime Minister has to resign
because um he's been found to have
believed colleagues in the workplace and
I think the other thing for Rishi sunak
is that this is the third person from
his cabinet third very senior cabinet
minister the third Ally who's had to
resign in under a year there was um
Gavin Williamson uh again there were
bullying allegations around him there
was an investigation Nadeem Sahari over
the finances as uh as as Andy's just
said and now
um uh Dominic Robb uh over a bullying
investigation and these three men all
had things hanging over them when sunak
appointed them to cabinet and I think it
just shows where the conservative
parties I mean I think some of it will
cut through to voters and I think some
voters really do care about this it's
unclear how many voters whose Minds it
will change though given that we've
already seen people having to sit down
from the cabinet because of um bullying
allegations but I also think the other
thing that it's quite symbolic of is the
fact that you know the conservative
party is a party sort of it really feels
like in the end days of a government
they've been in government for 13 years
now lots of sort of more distinguished
members the conservative government were
forced out over brexit and this is a
party really where you know Prime
Ministers are appointing people who've
got some really dodgy allegations
hanging over them and who ends up having
to resign months later so I think it
says something bigger and deeper about
the conservative party as well and the
fact that it really is in a sort of
phase of physics its existence where um
you know it's starting to look like it
needs a long spell enough position well
one thing's for sure whatever happens
Rishi sunette can't afford to have many
more days like this and he wanted to
talk to you about Hamza Yusuf briefly
because he'll be counting His blessings
there's no elections in Scotland
uh yeah I mean talk about starts for
prime minister first ministers it has
been obviously a Dreadful start for
homes I used to have and not of his own
making at all it would have been the
same had Kate Forbes won because really
neither of those candidates would have
had any idea uh what was coming at all
and Hamza Yusuf has come into government
as first minister of Scotland with the
worst entry of any first minister in the
history of devolution it's an
exceptionally difficult job that he's
come into
um and by a factor of many is more
difficult than his predecessor so he's
got about 18 months before he has his
first electoral test at the Westminster
elections but his problem there is that
his Watermark is incredibly high he has
48 seats out of the 59 in Scotland and
nobody on any side of politics thinks he
can keep them all so it's almost
inevitable that he will lose seats and
come under further pressure so you know
there are there are a lot of problems um
for Hamza use of a lot of problems for
the SNP although they still lead in the
pools and so yeah at the moment I'm sure
humble Yusuf will be thinking that the
first couple of weeks could not really
have been any worse than they have been
okay great to hear your thoughts Andy
Sonia thanks so much for joining us hope
to see you soon
um let's move on to other news now
or security at the Scottish Grand
National will be ramped up today after
protesters stormed last Saturday's Grand
National more than 100 protesters were
arrested at Aintree that was last
weekend with some entering the course
but organizers said they had no evidence
there would be disruption at today's
meet
the local government Association has
called for candidates standing in next
month's local elections to be treated
with respect a survey by the group found
a rise in attacks on candidates with
seven in ten councilors experiencing
abuse or intimidation last year over a
quarter also said they felt personally
at risk in the role
firefighters have now extinguished this
major fire that broke out above an
Indian restaurants in five yesterday
look at that at the fire spread through
the top floor and roof of the property
in Central and firmland no injuries were
reported
well now to the great tomato shortage
you may remember images of empty shelves
in the supermarkets earlier this year
that were put down to bad weather in
Spain and north of Africa but the number
of tomatoes grown in Britain is at the
lowest since records began back in 1985
or Alice Porter reports on one producer
which has found a solution but you may
not want to hear it
from sewage
to salad
these massive greenhouses produce
peppers and are mostly powered by heat
from our waste rather than using fossil
fuels of gas or gas oil to actually
create that heat through a boiler the
glass houses are for a circular economy
thinking actually extracting them to
heat from here and using it to grow
their crops the company says they're
reducing their carbon footprint by 75
percent compared with conventional
gas-powered greenhouses
and as long as people keep flushing
their toilets they have a stable supply
of energy
traditional greenhouses in the UK use a
lot of gas to keep them warm but with
Energy prices having risen by more than
156 since 2019 many farmers are
struggling to keep their doors open
which is why low carbon farming
facilities like these are so important
and these Growers believe it could be a
way to prevent the empty shelves we saw
earlier in the year we're heavily
reliant on imported crops up to 80
percent of of salad crops are imported
from the EU and further afield
um that obviously has the impact of
water stress energy food miles Etc we
have a domestic solution here to that
problem growing within the UK growing in
an environmentally sustainable way with
low energy use renewable energy use and
low water use the investors behind the
greenhouses say they want to build 40
more sites but Farms like these are not
eligible for any tax relief on their
energy bills and are calling on the
government to be included in their
energy intensive scheme there are two
options here one is the consumers pay
more for their food I think everybody
wants to avoid that the other is that
government allows the sector to be able
to access its scheme that will make a
massive difference at the moment and
everybody is losing out the government
says they have provided nearly 6 billion
pounds to businesses to help with high
energy costs but with Farmers warning
that food insecurity will continue it
may not be enough
Alice Porter Sky News
okay coming up after the break we'll
have a full run through of today's front
pages and of course Dominic Robb is on
nearly all of them all of that more
after the break
[Music]
well let's take a look at the latest
skiing snowfall because we need to have
a look at that but we won't this is live
TV my friends so sometimes things go
wrong but bear with me because what
we're going to do actually
and more appropriately is going to take
a look at the papers and we're going to
review them with the national world
cities editor-in-chief Nancy Fielder as
well as broadcaster Pete price good
morning to you all great to see you both
um as I said live TV things sometimes go
wrong but Nancy
um I wanted to talk to you about the
front page of the Guardian not talking
about ra but it's uh these serious
allegations then about CBI
these are incredibly serious allegations
in fact they've been sort of coming out
over a few days now this is the second
allegation about
um who said she was raped I mean the
details are absolutely horrendous and
she's claiming that the culture of
support wasn't there the sort of
allegations that people encouraged not
to go to the police when problems came
up so CBI has suspended everything for a
couple of months is it's going to speak
to everybody involved um obviously
prompted by lots of the biggest names
who were members putting out and saying
there wasn't nothing further to do with
it and they will come back together in
June and decide if it's got a future it
looks in doubt now though the
allegations are horrendous and it feels
like there's more coming out every day
so nothing positive for the CBI at the
minute in fact it's closed down no
interesting isn't it the heads of uh
John Lewis and NatWest all big a posts
held by women and and they're trying to
take that forward and of course making a
stand there Pete shall we um will you go
to the other end now and and your story
is quite interesting
um also this this is
um the mirror page six this is and this
is all about eating out and the cost of
actually
um will you take it away I won't take
all your lines tell me about that
you can have all my life you can even do
the yeah the skiing report if you're
like
I am I made up with this dinner parties
are coming back in fashion at home and I
used to be a caterer when you two
weren't born I was a caterer and we had
prawn cocktails and we have black forest
gateau and it was Sensational and I used
to love my dinner parties well
restaurants are getting very expensive
and this article is all about this and
it is fascinating and they're moving
away people are moving away from the
Casual kitchen supper and wanting people
to dress for dinner and come more
formally I I I it I love it I love
entertaining well I used to love him
staying at home I had six ladies round
who ate me out of the house and home
drank me best part and I said you're not
coming back again and now I've made me
dining room into a lounge so but I think
it's great that because when you go out
you've got the taxis you've got all the
costings and the price on the wide
scandals and there's always the clock
watching I find when you're having a
dinner party at home you're thinking got
the washing up to do when are they going
to leave by the time I get to bed it's
gone midnight I'm a terrible I'm all for
going out Nancy um let's move on then to
page two of the times it's all about
motorways
that's right this this is the Smart
motorways there's been yet another
increase and another tragedy where
somebody has died because there are no
hard shoulders on them on large eggs in
the M1 under the smart motorways now
this is calling for not only no more
smart weight motorways we've built which
the government has already said but
actually bring back hard shoulders and
and the government's showing no signs of
bringing back hard shoulders and I live
like five minutes from the M1 it feels
hugely dangerous you read these stories
all the time and there are tens of
thousands of people every single day
driving on motorways that aren't safe
they've got to be brought back we do
need somewhere so that if a car breaks
down you're not worried that you're
gonna die because because they made a
mistake it not much always complete
nonsense the name is the most ridiculous
thing about them but actually driving
somewhere in our country thinking you're
gonna die because of a bad design is
ludicrous no money should be held back
on this they've got to bring back the
hotel I I haven't spoke to one most
motorists who says that smart motorways
are the way forward
um so Pete Look age is nothing but a
number and you've found that in uh The
Daily Mail talk to us a bit about aging
they're saying that um it's quite simply
if you relax
um it will slow down the aging process
and you have to keep away from stress
and strain and it's just again I'm Aging
in this job I can tell you that
you're Aging in this job aging
age are keeping me young I love working
hard I love stress I love aggravation I
love doing this and I tell you what all
those people that are upset with their
our politician because they're being
bullied oh that's going to age them as
well
okay uh Nancy I love this story that you
picked out again in the guardian
um where do we begin with this pet
parrots are allowed to make video calls
to other birds really so well yes
apparently so there's been thousands of
pirates involved in this research which
shows that they're much happier and feel
less isolated if you let them do what
effectively conference calls like we're
doing now they could even had pictures
on their tablets of which palette they
could pick and so it's some came out
more popular than others it's incredible
I mean it just shows that perhaps it's
not just human beings who get lonely
when they're on their own and these poor
Powers live all day long on their own
when no other parents in sight and I
think it's hilarious I would love to see
some of those video calls
um can you imagine oh absolutely guys
you've really kept me company thank you
so much Nancy Fielder and Pete price
thank you we'll be talking to you in the
second hour thanks so much
um well still to come on Skinny's
breakfast
former deputy prime minister Dominic
Robb accuses activists civil servants of
forcing him out of office will have all
of that and a little bit more after the
break stay with Sky News breakfast
[Applause]
[Music]